- Biolyse, qui produit
des médicaments contre le
cancer, enauauautres, a été
fondée il y a 42 ans
par un biologiste
gaspésien et son épouse.
La mission de l'entreprise :
réduire le coût des médicaments,
pour qu'ils soient
accessibles à tous.
CLAUDE MERCURE,
cofondateur, Biolyse Pharma
- Le concept de ce qu'on dit
à ces gens-là, c'est : On ne
veut pas vous aider. On est trop
préoccupés pour vous aider.
Puis je ne pense pas
ça représente vraiment
le coeur des Canadiens.
- En mars dernier,
Claude Mercure a demandé
au gouvernement fédéral
le droit de produire des vaccins
anti-COVID génériques,
pour les vendre à une fraction
du coût à la Bolivie.
Le Canada peut suspendre
temporairement un brevet
si le vaccin ou le médicament
est offert à un pays à faible
revenu. Neuf mois plus tard,
il attend toujours la réponse.
- C'est assez compliqué,
même communiquer avec eux autres
à ce sujet-là. Et ils ne
répondent pas vraiment.
C'est parce qu'ils voulaient
plaire à... comme on dit en
anglais, à Big Pharma.
Ils ne voulaient pas initier
de la compétition Canada.
- En tout cas, l'épouvantail
des compagnies pharmaceutiques
qui intimident ou qui
découragent les pays à faire
la levée des brevets
est apparemment réel.
- L'ancienne présidente
de Médecins sans frontières
rappelle que lors de la pandémie
de SIDA en Afrique, le Canada
a été le premier pays, sous
le leadership de Jean Chrétien,
à adopter un régime permettant
de suspendre temporairement
un brevet. Ça été fait pour la
trithérapie au Rwanda et pour le
vaccin contre la grippe aviaire.
Pourquoi ne pas y recourir
pour les vaccins anti-COVID?
Dre JOANNE LIU,
Université McGill
- Je me l'explique difficilement
puis je pense que c'est pour ça
que je fais des entrevues.
C'est que je veux qu'on mette
la pression sur le gouvernement
canadien. Nous avons une
compagnie qui est prête à en
faire, qui est Biolyse. Et donc,
on a besoin aujourd'hui
que notre gouvernement canadien
mette sur l'Annexe 1,
qu'il rajoute les produits
à la COVID-19.
- Pour la médecin qui conseille
l'OMS, la panique provoquée
par le variant Omicron devrait
convaincre Ottawa d'appuyer
la levée des brevets COVID.
Surtout que les États-Unis
et la France y sont favorables.
- La réalité, c'est qu'on va
probalement s'asseoir
sur notre stockpile,
sur notre approvisionnement
parce qu'on va dire : Oh my God,
on a besoin d'une 3e dose et
si ca se trouve, peut-être
une 4e dose s'il y a un autre
variant, donc on est pas prêts à
donner nos vaccins.
- Le Canada n'a fourni
que 9 des 200 millions de doses
promises aux pays pauvres.
Lever les brevets leur
permettrait de produire des
vaccins abordables et ainsi,
freiner le développement
de nouveaux variants.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréa